Oh Simmons able to get the foul on  Harkless picked up two early personal  fouls and now he's got three two team  fouls apiece Simmons will go to the  stripe with Joelle and bead Hey coming  out to view things on the bench  [Applause]  I just feel better when he's in the  building to see big boy there be nice to  be had number 21 on shooting out a  second straight left knee pay he will  miss Monday's game at New Orleans as  well and he will be re-evaluated shortly  after that unfortunately an MRI showing  no structural damage we have double  technicals being dealt out here Ben  Simmons one of them and use of Newark  itch the other and you could almost hear  from here the two of them kind of jaw at  one and on the knee  [Music]